I don't really care you know this match
isn't set yet but are you in training
now yeah yeah so are you still doing
this thing you posted this video and
it's a training technique of everything
before so is this a genuine training
just made from a normal cap elastics
drinking a tennis ball boxes like that
sweaty
this is oh yeah it's the exciting game
that everybody like yes
that is reality we live in because that
was about the 1000 that I had done that
looked good I'm not good at this you're
already good in the video can we see the
video it's bad boy does this means you
will be able to defeat any tennis ball
it is much harder than it looks I try it
I'm good at this I try this is off doing
cuz it does that does not look hard does
it mmm that does not look hard no let's
try to see so do you throw it up and hit
it or what do you see however you feel
comfortable there's no right or wrong
technique but just keep it away from
your face
the right camera right quickly it's
music time does that not look like fun
we have one for everybody in the chasing
Oak Park
you